Ron is on Facebook. "Dave, What are your thoughts on pet insurance?"
Um, if you cannot afford to have your pet taken care of, you should not buy a pet.
'You don't like animals; you're an animal hater!' No, I'm an animal lover. I have two dogs.
We just lost one a while back, and got us back down to two. Our pug went to heaven.
And all pugs, go to heaven, of course. And
we have a Shih Tzu and we have a golden retriever. The golden retriever can actually talk, um,
better than some of you. We love our pets. They are wonderful. They are, however, dogs and
we have a reasonable economic outlook on them as animals. They are not humans.
We love them. I always cry when one of them leaves.
I cry like a thirteen-year-old girl watching Romeo and Juliet when the dogs leave.
I just bawl. I love my little pets, but they are dogs.
They are not human. And,
so, you should not take on the responsibility of a pet if you cannot afford to take care of it.
'Well Chemo[therapy] is
$10,000.'
Fluffy ain't gonna make it.
'You're mean!' No, I'm not mean. It's an animal, people!
We have to keep our brains plugged in.
See, the problem is my wife grew up on a farm, and animals left every week and went somewhere called "bye-bye".
And, um, like Jeff Foxworthy said, he said, 'we had a cat that tore up our--my mom's curtains and the next day that cat "ran away".' (laughter)
Yeah, so Sharon grew up on the farm, and these animals were always "running away".
And we just understand that they're animals. We love them. We have a heart, we're not mean,
we're not nasty people, but sometimes people have gotten so confused in our culture about this,
and there's such good
companions... If
you're, you know, a single person, or you're, you're widowed or something, and, and, you know, your cat or your dog it's,
it's one of your best friends. I get that. But you have to use your brain about this stuff, and
sometimes folks don't. And so, you know,
you know. 'Well, you're a multi-millionaire, you wouldn't spend $10,000 on your dog?' I might... but I can afford it.
An,-and, I kind of doubt it. You know...
I'm just, you know, it would break my heart though. I mean I cuz I just, hey, I'm telling you man,
I love those animals. They're wonderful, and, and, like I say, every time one of them goes to heaven,
I just cry.
But that's, that's, they're just animals. And I know some of you are going to send your little
Liberal crazy political correct--correct hate mail on Twitter. Just have at it. Just get in line.
You know, because, ah, you know this is called 'The Dave Ramsey Show' for a reason.
It's what Dave Ramsey thinks about something. If you want to know what people know what you think, gets you a show, that's how this
will work, okay? So, Ron asked me, and that's what we're doing here. That's my thoughts on pet insurance.
I don't have pet insurance. I don't recommend it.
I recommend you not take on the responsibility and animal if you cannot afford to take care of them.
And if you can't, you know, and at some point, the care of them
becomes economically
unreasonable given that they're an animal. And
you have to look at that. And it's sad, y'all, I get it. I understand them. I'm being a smart-aleck,
an' sarcastic, but--it just--I'm the same way. I'm just a big, Ol
Hearted Softy when it comes to them.
But I'm not going to lose my mind, either, in the process, nor am I gonna lose my perspective on what's really going on here.
Hey guys, thanks for watching! If you enjoyed this video click, the subscribe button
to get the latest content and check out these other great clips from the show! (music)